Salam alaikum we're gonna take a break
with my father here and Bible there was
a story that he's shared with me quite a
few times and I thought that you guys
can go ahead and benefit from this story
Bob do you mind sharing the story that
you have told me a few times with
everybody I said I'm alaikum as my
mother he some long long time ago I
heard the story from the my dentist but
father and son you know mostly fathers
those days also there was not raising
kids the way should be whatever and then
when father father felt that he must go
yes the son sound please can you do me a
favor
looks like I gonna go first so he was
about to die
yes and so not sure why not
here I'd already two envelopes close
number one number two say he is a number
one please when I die open up this
number one and read after they buried me
from burial open number two can you do
this it's a sure father least okay
and short while after this one father
passed away his son God knows what he
was thinking maybe he's left a veil or
something some hiding money god knows
what he was thinking Sony open number
one dear son please don't let them bury
me without socks
so son understand event rather way and
he bought the good socks and they was
taking him his father to Vashem
preparing for burial janazah and he went
over there it's at all those two guys
who wash his father please you know this
is my father I will take care of you do
me a favor when you finish washing him
put those socks on him he said no no no
we cannot do it why not this is my
father this is his wish say no no sir
not lets me in tradition you know
teaching of Prophet Muhammad SAW as
Salam we naked coming neck and go no
socks no shoes nothing but if you call
go over there and as this main Imam you
know maybe he he will okay I don't know
an event over there even a skinny mom he
explained what was father wish he said
the same thing no no no way this is we
cannot break in our tradition you know
no way no no and they buried his father
with no socks just the way should be
after burial he hurry up go over there
in open open this number to guess what
let's know will nothing just father's
advice or so dear son did you see they
don't let you even take the socks with
you when you die you know
and I like this really advice to
everybody to think about it you know
when it comes time to go I've really
prepared you know this greediness that's
mean son was probably greedy and you
know this dunya only dunya only dunya
father for sure
teach him you know that's aji de the way
I see you know then Allah knows I don't
know what's the next our son end up
anyway I think that's good story that my
dentist he said I was telling me so the
father was trying to teach the son a
lesson here that he was just mainly
focused on this dunya acquiring money
wealth he wasn't living his purpose and
this was kind of a reminder that the the
father left for the Sun a little bit
that he can do to teach him a lesson
that all that wealth and money it's
gonna stay behind exactly but what about
what you work for in this life the
currency that transfers over is when you
work to please your Creator before at
the time comes and you have to meet your
Creator you will leave everything behind
and the only thing that you're going to
go ahead and take with you is your deeds
your wealth and your family everything
stays behind but your belief what you
believe in this life and then what you
acted upon and those good deeds those
deeds of goodness that you planted those
would transfer over into the next so let
that be a reminder hope this was a good
break I want to share that story with
you and hopefully this can be a benefit
so I'll make them taste be with you